hi everybody thank you for being here my
name is Brittany and like I mentioned I
recently moved out to Denver to be an
instructor at turing school of software
and design so I've been teaching
front-end web application development
for about two years now and one of the
things that we really emphasize with our
students is that they should be using
proper vocabulary and articulating
themselves appropriately when they're
talking about their code our students
had a tendency to have a block of code
and they would describe it by saying
things like oh well you know this thing
calls this over here and then that moves
over here and this thing calls this and
sends this information over there and
we're like what I don't understand what
you're saying so we were teaching them
all the proper terms to use and all the
terms that they should avoid as well and
in doing so I started to realize that we
had a lot of bizarre jargony words in
our industry that we use words that I
wouldn't normally think twice about my
students would either laugh at or ask me
questions about and I realized I didn't
know how to explain some of them so that
prompted me to do a little bit of
research and look into some of the
terminology that we use when we're
talking about code and while we're
programming okay so I made a tiny list
of words that I'm going to talk about
today with all of you our first example
is the the term bug and this is one of
the most classic origin stories that we
have in programming some of you might
already be familiar with it but for
those of you who aren't the term bug was
popularized in the 1940s by a Harvard
University technical team they found an
actual moth in one of their machines
that was causing it to malfunction so
noted computer scientist Grace Hopper
moved that moth and taped it to a log a
bug lock if you will with a caption
first actual case of bug being found
okay so this wasn't the very first
instance of that term being used in
programming the phrase bugs in a
computer had been used quite frequently
before then back in the that day but
computers were really big and they were
really hot so they often attracted flies
and mobs that would cause the machines
to malfunction so even though this team
didn't coin the term this particular
incident is what caused that widespread
usage and popularity of the term bug
which ultimately led rise to the term
debugging as well since then a couple of
people have criticized the term bug
because it distances the developers from
blame it implies that it was something
other than developer error that caused
the program to malfunction so some
computer scientists have offered up a
couple of alternatives like defect and
my favorite blunder neither of them
really took off although I would love to
see us create blunder reports I think
that would be hilarious so I think bug
is is pretty much here to stay okay so
that's one of the most concrete examples
of an origin story that we have for a
term that we're using in programming
other words are a little bit hazy ER or
it's a little bit more difficult to
track down
concrete origins of where they came from
but they still have really interesting
theories behind them and interesting
metaphors that we can pull out of them
one of my favorite examples of these
terms is throw-and-catch so when you're
programming maybe you have some try
catch blocks and you're going to throw
an exception that is going to be caught
okay so the first appearance of these
terms in programming were introduced in
Mac Lisp which is a dialect of the
language in 1972 so they introduced two
new error handling primitives which were
throw and catch the lead developers
working on this language at the time
were American and in America the sport
of baseball is really popular I know
it's not very widespread elsewhere
probably because it's incredibly boring
but it offers some potential insight
into an explanation for these particular
terms so in baseball a player can commit
what's actually called a throwing error
so a player might throw the ball just
slightly out of reach for their
teammates or the ball might take an
unexpected bounce or maybe it hits a
teammate or a base any number of things
could go wrong there but ultimately the
goal for each one of these throws is to
catch that ball to reduce the amount of
damage that that error is actually going
to do right so we have the same concept
in programming where we want to catch
any exceptions that are thrown and
surface those errors as soon as possible
and provide as much information about
what went wrong so that our programs
don't fail in these really catastrophic
ways okay so that's an example of one of
the theories that is not completely set
in stone a little bit more speculative
but still offers us a metaphor on how to
think about these terms that we work
with every day okay let's talk about
fubar a little bit how many people use
these medicine tactic variables
fubar bass okay meet you I or I used to
and I stopped recently and I'll get into
that in a little bit people understand
why yep okay so fubar was first used in
programming by mi t--'s tech Model
Railroad Club and this club was
essentially a bunch of
nerds or kids playing with model train
sets right they built this complex
system for automating train sets and
these systems had a bunch of kill
switches where you would trigger one of
these if something terrible was going to
happen something catastrophic was
happening so maybe one of the trains was
going to crash into another train or
some other obstruction and they had this
little dashboard alongside their system
that usually showed like a counter or a
clock something of that sort but
whenever one of these kill switches was
engaged the dashboard instead flashed
the word foo okay
so think about how foo was being used
here to represent and denote that
something terrible happened okay so this
leads us into the origin of where foo
bar came from as an instructor I do a
lot of demonstrative coding and white
boarding for my students and I was using
foo bar for a while until one of my
students who was a veteran was
explaining that foo bar was actually a
military slang term that stood for
messed up beyond all recognition right
so people would use this term talking
about the missions that they were on
often sometimes the severity of the
injuries that soldiers sustained right
and in the tech world we decided to try
to soften the definition of this acronym
and we were like oh it doesn't stand for
that it actually stands for fouled up
beyond all repair for our software and
we changed the spelling a little bit but
we still maintains that phonetic
composition that we have with this term
right so even though we're trying to
soften the way that we use these terms
or make them a little bit more gentle
those original conceptions are still
there right and this term could still be
very triggering for for certain people
and the software engineering community
no lack of terms with negative
connotations to them think about the
terms master/slave we have done a pretty
decent job of trying to get that out of
our vocabulary but it wasn't always very
easy in 2003 the city of Los Angeles or
County of Los Angeles had filed a
request that manufacturers stop using
those terms in their products and the
tech being industry being the tech
industry was all like no we want to keep
our terms master/slave like don't tell
us what to do and they got really angry
about it so Los Angeles was kind of like
oh sorry never mind it was just a
request and kind of backed off but the
following year the global language
monitor decided to name master/slave as
the most politically incorrect term of
2004 which was a really great response
to that incident I thought whitelist
blacklist I had another scenario in
class one day where one of my students
saw some documentation on mdn that used
a variable called whitelist
and they were trying to rework some of
the code in that example but they were
putting things that should be blocked
into this whitelist array and as I was
trying to explain to him what it meant I
was like oh well think about the
difference between a whitelist and a
blacklist and I kind of stopped myself
short realizing how negative those terms
are and the modern-day connotations that
those have nowadays so the origin of
those terms it for anyone that might not
be following those terms imply that
anything that is white is good and
anything that is black is bad right and
there's a lot of different reasons for
the origins of those terms and maybe
perhaps when they came around they
weren't necessarily racist or they
didn't hold the connotations that they
do today but because they hold those
connotations today they should
definitely be removed from our
vernacular as well from our vocabulary
okay I'm going on tangents here so let
me get back to a couple other words
thunk okay so thunks are subroutines
used to inject additional logic or
calculations into other subroutines
so I teach react and redux at Turing and
this is where we introduce our students
to thunks they use Redux think for some
of their actions
asynchronous actions out there they're
creating and they're always like what on
earth is a thunk I have no idea and a
lot of people think this term originated
because of a sound they think very
clearly about a sound that would be
occurring from this so maybe it was the
sound of data hitting the some kind of
information hitting this the stack or
data hitting an accumulator that's what
a lot of people reference this term too
but the origin is actually from a very
late night of programming years ago
where a couple of developers were
thinking really hard about how they
needed this type of argument at a
certain point in execution of their
program and they didn't have that value
right away but they realized that they
could get that information in advance
with a couple by adding a couple extra
calculations at compile time and in
their minds they thought okay if we add
these calculations ahead of time now
this variable this value has already
been thought of it's already been
thought about
hence thunk is the past tense version of
think or past tense of think so that's
what that term actually means here it
was a very late night of programming for
them so if you think really hard about
it eventually it will make sense okay
shells this was a fun one to research so
the analogy here the metaphor here is
actually quite simple it is literally
just a nut so the shell what we think
about as our command line or our
terminal what we're actually interacting
with
is our shelf and we are interacting with
this shell rather than the kernel or the
central core of our operating system
right so not work the same exact way
nuts have there they're a fruit and they
have this very hard external shell that
does not allow you access to that inner
seed or that that inner kernel right so
that's the metaphor there when I was
researching this one there were a lot of
threads where people were getting very
philosophical about things and really
deep about what it could possibly mean
they were like oh the shell is like a
seashell from the ocean and there are
there's this concept of listeners and
you can listen to the ocean just like
with you when you put a seashell up to
your ear and people were just making up
these very convoluted metaphors and then
finally someone commented and was just
like listen it's just a nut like that's
all it is
and the conversation stopped after he
mentioned that so we have a tendency to
overthink things for sure when we try to
come up with metaphors and examples of
what things might mean okay so that's
just a handful of words that I have
picked out from a very long list if
you're interested in learning more words
and learning more terminology there's a
book called the new hackers dictionary
which isn't actually quite new anymore
it's actually pretty dated I think it
was around 1996 when it was being
actively updated but there's a lot of
other terms in that dictionary that are
pretty humorous like Wagga Wagga Barth
ulation
nasal demons so these are all considered
hacker programmer terms I don't know
what any of them mean but I got a good
laugh as I was looking through that
glossary reading some of these terms but
at the same time alongside these more
humorous and more interesting terms in
this dictionary there's also a lot of
really upsetting words
words that very clearly indicate some of
the cultural issues that we are still
dealing with today in programming words
like tits on a keyboard tar and feather
rape these are all considered
programming terms according to that
dictionary right in the beginning of
that book
they say all human cultures use slang in
this threefold way as a tool of
communication and of inclusion and of
exclusion I want to take the last part
of this talk to talk a little bit about
this exclusion piece one of the ways in
which the language that we use in
programming is the most exclusionary
lies in how biased it is towards native
english-speakers how much it favors
native English speakers I had a student
recently who was a perfectly talented
developer she was very able to write all
the code and build all of the
applications but where she felt she was
falling behind as a native Spanish
speaker was that grasping that
articulation piece so talking about the
code and listening to others speak about
it the terms and metaphors that we use
that might make perfect sense to you
might be absolutely meaningless to
someone else there was a discussion on a
github thread recently where a developer
was discussing how the terms property
and attribute translate to the exact
same word in Chinese even though they
mean slightly different things when we
talk about them in English so their
solution here to overcome this was
- prefix that word with either Dom when
they were talking about add-on property
or HTML when they're talking about an
HTML attribute that would help them
avoid any confusion that they might have
ran into this was really eye-opening to
me and I wanted to hear more stories
what else was out there
and how are people struggling with in
this industry dominated by English so I
interviewed a couple of developers and I
surveyed about 30 which is still a
pretty small sample set but I was
surveying some non-native English
speakers just about some of their
experiences being engineers being
developers and working in this technical
space that is so biased towards English
speakers
so one of the main themes that came up
was that there was a longer learning
curve for these developers so not only
were they trying to learn the
programming language at the same time
they were trying to learn the written
and spoken language that explained it in
the first place
sometimes there were no translations for
certain terms that we use in programming
sometimes there would be a translation
but maybe it would cause even more
confusion if that translation wasn't a
perfect one-to-one correlation with the
original term on a by alice developer up
in new york times and native polish
speaker said i have no idea what polish
people call a variable in Polish not
knowing the words in my native language
definitely adds some sense of
artificiality to the programming terms
so it's very difficult to derive meaning
from terms that seem like they are
made-up terms that you have not
recognized in your native language right
another theme I noticed was that people
had difficulty getting help
also recognizing when they actually
needed help so some people mentioned
that it was challenging to find the
right search terms to use when tackling
a bug that they were encountering I know
I still have problems with that as a
native English speaker so there's an
added layer of complexity there for some
people a lot of people mentioned reading
issue threads and pull requests wasn't
worth it
because there was too much slang
involved in those threads that
convoluted the discussion and made it
really difficult for them to follow the
developer I was just talking about Anna
was also mentioning that when she would
read documentation she would have to
double-check with her coworkers
do I not understand this because it's
poorly written or jus not I not
understand this because of a gap in my
English proficiency right so this was
another check that people had to do for
themselves in order to understand
whether or not it was them or something
that was pre-written poorly we all know
how much documentation is written poorly
out there and how many bad resources
there are out there so I can't imagine
having that additional challenge yes by
far one of the biggest barriers for
people seemed to be community
involvement and the judgment that came
along with that so I think everyone here
can agree that community involvement is
so essential for your growth and your
learning and enjoyment and success in
the industry right in your career and
it's such a vital part of being involved
in this industry that it's a shame that
people feel start to feel left out of it
some people mentioned that they would
have a hard time following a technical
conversation not because they weren't
skilled enough or because they didn't
have the technical knowledge but simply
because it would be a large group of
people talking very fast about a
particular topic and that made it
challenging for them to follow along
which made it look as if they didn't
know what people were talking about my
friend Belen mentioned that she produces
materials in English like screencasts
and articles and talks and sometimes
people will question her materials or
her technical prowess her skill set
because of a spelling or grammar mistake
or or her accent very simple things and
there's this added layer of having to
prove yourself now if you have this
barrier
that most of us are unfamiliar with
right so a lot of people did say some
positive things about their community
involvement but overall the tone felt
kind of lonely and I think this is
something that we should definitely be
working on as an industry and based on
some of the responses that I was getting
there were definitely some things that
stood out to me that we could start
doing and things that people mentioned
so one of those was when you're creating
resources try to use more illustrations
and charts and graphs those are more
Universal and often helped clarify
things we're written text falls short
Lin Clark got a really great shout out
from one of the respondents for all of
the work that she's been doing there so
if we could all make an effort to do
something more like that I think that
would be super helpful limiting the
slang that we use in issues and PR
threads if we can aim for words that
might be translated more easily in other
languages it might feel silly at first
it might feel robotic at first but it
would help break down some barriers for
certain developers that I think would be
super helpful and then lastly we need to
be working with native speakers of other
languages to create these resources to
create better resources more Universal
resources and I'm not exactly sure just
what this looks like yet but I'm hoping
to collect more data and more
experiences so that we can figure that
out so I'm sure a lot of people here
have dealt with some of these issues
they've experienced these things I would
love to hear from all of you if you have
I plan on keeping my survey open
indefinitely so that people can continue
to respond to it so I'll tweet that out
in a little bit but any experiences that
you have anything that you think that we
can be doing to alleviate some of these
difficulties that were causing for other
developers I would love to talk with you
more about that okay feel free to find
me during the breaks or after all the
talks will be around today if you have
any insights or experiences you want to
share or maybe even some other terms and
origin stories that you find really
interesting I'd love to hear about them
hope you enjoy the rest of the
conference thank you
[Applause]